this Divine principle governs all things
a pantheistic god that is reason itself
thus nature is perfectly and reasonably
ordered everything happens according to
the will or Providence of this God or
logos and everything is thus
pre-ordained when we read the stoic
writings we find that they are often
concerned with this idea of how God
orders all things according to perfect
reason and that we are to appreciate the
Perfection of the world or at least to
see everything that happens or changes
as indifferent the logos is after all
identical to Nature including our own
nature God is within and without it is
everywhere it is nature itself and it
moves and changes according to the
reason of the logos which is also
identical to itself and this is what it
means to quote live according to Nature
to align oneself with the way that
nature works with the Divine logos